illegal immigration is high on the
agenda as the e used justice and Home
Affairs Council meets and Luxembourg
ministers will be briefed about
developments with the task force
Mediterranean which was set up to help
avoid deaths at sea following the
tragedy of the Italian island of land
producer in October the task force has
identified key priorities including
better cooperation with third countries
to limit illegal migration boosting the
fight against trafficking and crime
tougher border surveillance and
increased solidarity with EU state under
high migration pressures the ministers
will discuss the update and could
explain how they intend to implement the
priorities the issue of foreign fighters
from Europe heading to Syria will also
be discussed in the wake of the shooting
of the Jewish Museum in Brussels last
month at leged Lee by a man who fought
in Syria ministers will be briefed by
the EU counterterrorism coordinator
Hilda kerkove I was asked to report on
the state of implementation on may four
main aspect the measures we can take to
prevent people from going to Syria the
detection of suspicious travel the
criminal response and relation with the
third countries and especially the
transit countries justice affairs
ministers will focus on data protection
aiming to agree parts of new draft rules
governing the way the EU protects
people's personal information online the
Greek presidency will inform the council
about the state of play of a proposal
aiming to protect data used in the
prevention investigation detection and
prosecution of a crime